hey so i'm just getting back from ces
and if you don't know what that is it's
the consumer electronics show in vegas
they have one every year and it is such
an overwhelming event because they have
so many gadgets electronics and
everything just spread out all over the
convention center that it's pretty hard
to see everything i was there for two
days and i honestly
was just so overwhelmed and i shot so
much video that i couldn't fit into one
so what i did was split all of the
videos up across a few of my channels
here on youtube i have youtube.com slash
other augustine where i post a lot of
vlogs and a new channel
youtube.comreviews where i'm gonna start
posting reviews of gadgets electronics
iphone apps pretty much anything that i
feel like so i'm launching that channel
here with some stuff that i posted from
ces so here we go i've got all these
videos down here feel free to take your
pick and after you're done watching one
of those videos feel free to come right
back here and you can click on another
video and watch another one and yeah so
let's get this party started click click
don't worry i'm not going anywhere so
you can just come back here